good morning John and welcome to this
special report from the vlogbrothers
newsroom today January 3rd 2014 at 10
a.m. Pacific time the Golden Gate Bridge
did not collapse 110,000 vehicles were
safely conveyed over 8,000 feet from one
side of the bridge to the other
including cars trucks semi trucks not
even to mention the countless bicyclists
and pedestrians the bridge did not
collapse despite being exposed to harsh
weather conditions and constant
vibrations for more than 76 years death
count at this point is unknown but is
thought to be zero thanks for sharing
all the good news John and there is so
much good news but there's also bad news
including the fact that many people seem
to be physically incapable of believing
that there is good news in the world
there are a lot of comments on you video
and I'm not saying all but a lot saying
things like divorce rates are only down
because the economy is in shambles and
people can't afford them anymore infant
mortality is only done because there are
more abortions being performed yeah
people are getting cured of more
diseases but there are more diseased
people the minor net speeds didn't get
any faster so I don't believe it
it does actually seem hard to believe
that the world is getting better and
there are reasons for that and it's not
just cable news which we love to
complain about go on
psychology studies show that we wait bad
stuff happening to us about two times
more heavily than we wait good stuff
which means that we have to have like
two times more good stuff happen to us
just to think that the world is good
then we have bad stuff happened to our
second probability shelf your newspaper
only covered you in the 1001 murder per
lifetime but as we expand that circle to
all 7 billion people on the earth there
are terrible things happening pretty
much every moment of every day terrible
and unusual which our brains like to
know about just in case they might
affect us and so we pay attention to all
of it and it's just too much number 3
entropy things fall apart destroying
stuff is easy building it as hard the
universe tends toward disorder so just
keeping stuff from falling down is hard
like every day the Golden Gate Bridge
doesn't collapse is a victory that goes
uncelebrated and yet mostly bad stuff
doesn't happen so we were constantly
surrounded by good news which makes it
pretty boring so we don't talk about it
the big psychological theory of mind is
that our brains pick out unusual things
and focus on them and so we don't think
about all of the great stuff that just
works and happens and no problems
there's gas in the gas station and food
to the grocery store number four good is
gradual bad stuff happens in spikes like
stock markets crash they don't crash
upwards to down there's no good
equivalent of a terrorist attack you
can't crash a cancer cure into a
hospital and just through everybody's
battery can't go to the airport with a
gun that shoots healthy kidneys and then
shoot a bunch of late-stage diabetic
kidneys just fly it inside a people I
got four now good stuff happens
gradually over a long period of time and
that's okay
finally number five bias all these
factors pile up on each other and we
start to believe that only bad stuff
ever happens in the world and once we
believe that we only take into account
information that reinforces it this is a
cognitive bias called confirmation bias
what I think is why a lot of people were
trying to poke holes in what you said in
nuanced video John because it didn't fit
with the worldview if the world is
messed up and broken and going downhill
like crazy until you try to figure out
why that isn't the case when in fact it
just is the world's okay I'm not saying
though that it's all unicorns and
Sherlock premiers income inequality in
the u.s. is ridiculous we have the
highest incarceration rate in the world
and global climate change is going to
threaten the stability of everything I
got nothing against caution we should be
cautious but we should also not be
pessimistic cuz that's just gonna hold
us back John I'll see you on Tuesday I
drew these things on the back of hanker
fish drawings so if you got a
handkerchief is drawing there's a chance
that you will get one of these if you're
interested in psychology which is a lot
of what we were talking about in this
video I am pleased to announce that the
next season of crash course I will be
doing crash course psychology also go
subscribe to Grace's new channel
youtube.com slash its grace